hello everyone and welcome to the 20th
anniversary
celebration extravaganza party
celebrating 20 years of hedvig and the
angry inch my name is peppermint
and i know if you were anything like me
then you know exactly where you were the
first time you ever
heard of hedwig and the angry inch i was
working as a makeup artist at the makeup
counter during the day
for mac cosmetics when angry inch the
lipstick came out to celebrate the film
and at night i was working at don hills
uh
in drag as you know a superstar
a future superstar uh and i had no idea
that
20 years later i'd be here sitting with
the creators the stars and the
luminaries
of this very very
um transformative story
piece of art this cult classic
i was just beginning my gender journey
myself and i have so many
people to thank and they are all pretty
much in this panel
so i want to jump right in he is a tony
award-winning american writer
director performer songwriter singer
genius
he directed and starred and wrote with
steven trask the musical
hedvig and the angry inch and its
subsequent film and adaptation
please welcome my friend john cameron
mitchell
welcome john thank you
okay and hold up we have a grammy
award-nominated composer musician and
lyricist
who can pose all the music and lyrics
for the for the musical
and the film please welcome stephen
trask
thank you it's nice to be here john and
steven take us back to
the very beginning how did hedvig even
come about
the short thing is we met on an airplane
from la to new york i believe weirdly we
both had connections with new line
cinema who eventually made the film
stephen was reading scripts for new line
he had some family members who worked
there
i had just done a film called book of
love directed by the head of new line
bob shea
and we just started talking there was
when harry met sally was on the screen
and we both were the only two people not
watching it
he had a fossbender biography which was
on the seat between us which was an
icebreaker
which is which he's not usually breaking
any ice he's making ice
it was three years later when we kept
bumping into each other and i was i had
an
idea for a rock musical and i
we saw each other's work i saw his band
cheater at
cbgb's and he saw me in hello again at
lincoln center and we
you know peanut butter chocolate we got
to do something together
so so the head the hedwig character
wasn't really
there i think in the back of john's mind
he probably wanted
to base a character on helga his
babysitter but but when we started
working this character wasn't there but
i was
basically doing a hedwig style show with
the rock band and drag queens at
squeezebox every friday night and i was
music director
i knew the origin of love was going to
be the central metaphor
of the story that was the first song it
comes from plato it's a story of us
being cut in half
and seeking our other halves i gave
steven the text from plato and he came
back
with that song whole nothing changed
from that moment it was just like this
perfect
first song that's basically what we had
and then so john started telling me
about helgen then i said well why don't
we make
al get into a drag character
but she used to be a singer who used to
perform with our rock star
who was the lead character and john was
like what don't
you were a little reluctant to do it and
there was a little resistance to john
doing it but
we just kind of poured everything into
that first
show which was really a riot i mean it
was just
we really took our time in creating a
30-minute
mini musical squeezebox was a magical
place and and
peppermint we actually met at don hills
yeah dunhills which was the club
where squeezebox happened and it's a
legendary rock club
and michael schmidt who was friends of
ariana phillips
had this club he just wanted a place he
could hang out we were all like let's
get a place where
you know some rock and roll drags mostly
queer but
everyone's welcome you know no bad
behavior
this is a new thing for the early 90s
it was a stephen and my dream club
it was a dream club for i wouldn't say a
lot of people because a lot of people a
lot of gay men went to clubs but it was
for all the gay men who didn't like all
chelsea and this one exactly and we just
this was the place that we wanted to be
in the and there was
a thousand of us every friday night in
this club and
just so exciting it was like a home and
met
friends that are friends forever and
amazing drag performers who hadn't used
their voices they were used to lip
syncing
um suddenly found that they didn't have
to sing like you know
patty labelle when they're singing rock
and roll and punk
and they already were punk and didn't
even know it so you would get
mistress for micah sherry vine lady
bunny who
suddenly she's singing kate bush and
people are screaming like no one ever
did
for her but we were both learning from
these incredible
innate performances even pat briggs who
did this character called torment and
jimmy james who is used to doing marilyn
monroe but now it's marilyn monroe
singing
stairway to heaven zeppelin yeah yeah it
was unbelievable
and uh it was a ferment and i was
learning i was learning from the great
you know
jane county justin vivian bond these are
legends of drag and trans
rock that filled us up taught us and i
was just a little baby drag queen
yeah and i was learning you know i had
to learn four or five different songs
every week
it could be everything from the
buzzcocks to
someone would want to do a punk version
of a barbra streisand
song or a depeche mode so it didn't like
it was just every week it was a new
challenge musically
and it was a lot of growth for me as as
a
musician it's funny after our first gig
the scouts for woodstock 94 the
reboot of woodstock was there and they
were like
you're amazing we want you to perform it
woodstock
and i was like what i couldn't hear i
was like wig stock great i love wig
stuff
no woodstock and i don't know what
happened but i think squeezebox
the other queens were me were mad at me
because i wasn't a real drag queen and i
get the invitation to woodstock
so i wanted a group of people from
squeezebox but they couldn't find
dressing rooms you know
helicopters that demanded by mistress
formica
so that never happened but it was the
beginning it was the birth and
we kept doing gigs in clubs we wanted to
keep it out of the theater
because the theater tended to tone
everything down rock and roll wise
and so we uh developed it eventually
for the theater over four years at west
bat
at the palladium at you know uh
fire island you know porch parties where
everyone walked away
um we lived head pick's life
but then we finally with the great help
of peter askin
our amazing director our first director
and producer
we eventually landed in the j street
theater which
he built for hedwig because every
theater in town rejected us
public theater new york theater workshop
nobody wanted us we were too weird we
were too drag we were too punk
i was a fake drag queen a fake rock
singer and a fake stand-up comedian
but it was still too much for them so we
had to build a theater for us
too and it was so custom-made that that
the height of the stage
was set to the height of john in heels
and then people went and sat out
where the audience would sit and said
let's make the stage a little higher
like it was it was that was customer
yeah we built it for
hedwig's wig by that point we had
brought in miriam shore who just blew us
away
in an unexpected audition as he attacked
a hedwig's lover and backup singer and i
i had met mike potter at kim's video he
was one of the
surly clerk famously surly clerks at
kim's video who's like
i can't rent you this you haven't
watched it yet this is a classic
[ __ ] you get out the whole thing
and i said i'm going to squeeze boxes
like oh i go there and it's like i do
wig sometimes i need a wig done and he
did my second wig at the show which was
at squeezebox which was mike what was it
made out of
toilet paper rolls um with hair wrapped
around it
staples and hot glue and it fell apart
on stage
like the toilet perfectly dangling i was
like i'm fired and then he was like can
we do that again can that happen every
time and i was like
no that can't happen ever again i mean i
was like i was ready to walk out and be
like good luck
with your character because i knew i was
fired but i wasn't you've invoked mike
so mike hello
hi mike potter is a hair and makeup
artist extraordinaire who works in
editorial
advertising celebrity and motion picture
makeup
and he's also a painter collaborating
with john cameron mitchell
potter created hedwig's iconic wigs and
makeup
for the musical and film adaptation of
hedwig and the angry inch
so mike we we've invoked you and we we
we stopped at the toilet paper
roll wig wrapped in hair that
fell apart hopefully at the right moment
i mean it must have been the right
moment if we
if it was requested again it kind of
didn't fall apart what started bad
before that because when we were
standing at the bathroom door
before he was going on stage in said
toilet paper wig he had a cup of tea in
his hand
and someone opened the door and the tea
flew all over his
face hot tea and um it kind of like
it was like the first settings it was
setting yeah
it was the first setting spray ever made
then we moved forward we were doing like
fez and places like that and john wanted
to go
more structural so i was making if you
can imagine
you know the um the tubes that are a
dryer
has you know those plastic metal the big
tubes
oh yeah the metal ones yeah uh-huh i
have a picture of john because he
decided you want to do a side part
version where that wig is made out of
those
hair wrapped around that and i just
remember he snatched us and the wig
flew off you know i mean it was just a
series of unfortunate
disasters and events that kind of worked
for the character
over the years but you know john was
always and stephen
always had these beautiful songs and the
the singing and everything else kind of
made up for it and
it it became okay the the tragedy
of the hair and makeup yeah i mean i've
always said the only reason
is hedwig's hair and makeup is supposed
to be kind of bad
is is the way that i was successful in
that the end of that process
you failed beautifully you know rupaul
gets it right in terms of all the skills
needed to do drag meaning making your
own stuff
design you're a designer you're an
editor you're a director
performer sometimes a songwriter drag
and to a lesser extent stand up is the
most
fully formed kind of performance in that
you have to do it all and oftentimes
you're mixing your own damn
song putting your own track on
right i mean yeah i learned to play
on the player running to open the
curtain and then hurry up and get back
into
on position for the audience yes and
they're all like it's so glamorous
you're like
that gets to like like a thing that we
just sort of adapted
hedwig always was wherever hedwig was
and so then if something happened
it wasn't john and steven's performance
where stuff was going bad it was hedwig
and the angry inches performance exactly
stuff was going wrong and that was the
reality
and as long as you accepted that it
didn't matter you know we were out at
the jane street theater
like the the there would be leaks in the
bathroom upstairs and they'd have
dead bodies and yeah dead bodies and
pieces of
the set would come crashing down on us
you know
hit the bass player and he's like
bleeding and
we were in a we were in an sro hotel
which means
not standing room only but single room
occupancy
which is like a welfare hotel and we it
was like
german backpackers and junkies upstairs
and once the audience was coming in
and they were taking a body out and
that's that was
our gig we were outside the theater
system
i was such a theater queen and steven
was such a rock and roll queen so
we created a third space that was part
theater park cabaret part rock
to keep the character honest and then by
the time we got to off-broadway
uh we opened and nobody was interested
the critics really liked us but
audiences were horrified
often very silent shows like in the
movie
it was only the press kind of making it
hip you know it took
glenn close coming 20 times and the
press
agents making sure that the press was
always there
when a celebrity showed up and then they
would pack the house
with people with free seats and like
this huge hit downtown
that's sold out and all these
celebrities are coming it's like and the
celebrities would go away and the press
would leave and we performed like 20
people
it was it was totally fake but then it
would be like
marilyn manson and barry manilow were
there one night
elliott smith and madonna hedy lupone
you know it was just like this mix
was crazy pb herman david bowie and vr
lori anderson it pete burns it was out
of control
we were overwhelmed that our our heroes
were here and approving of us
you know and the drag legends too were
approving of it because i still
felt like a fake you know like not i
hadn't paid my dues
you know as a drag person so even though
we were limping along and never really a
hit
we stuck it in there and suddenly there
was a bidding war for the film
okay that is perfect timing you've
already uh
invoked her but i need to introduce her
properly
she is an actor and activist who starred
in film theater and television
and of course she starred as the attack
in the off-broadway musical hedwig and
the angry inch and then later reprised
the role
in the film please help me welcome
miriam shore hey miriam hi i'm so
excited to be here and thanks
so nice to meet you peppermint i'm just
a huge fan
i know you're one of the people that i
haven't actually met
not over you're kind of yeah sweating
and fangirling um
uh it's so it's so great to be here it's
so fun to think back to
all the time i was just remembering you
know me
i can remember so vividly meeting
stephen
and john it was the first audition
in new york city that my that i a person
ever sent me on
was for the work for the workshop talk
what do you mean that a person ever sent
you on
i met with an agent i was just a kid and
i met with an agent and they were like
oh we don't know maybe we'll send you
out on a few things we'll see how you do
and the first thing they sent me on was
to audition for a workshop version
of hedwig wasn't even fully a play yet
so i was like oh this is amazing i mean
this is so
what is this you know and i have a piece
of paper
that i wrote all the notes down on they
were like i wrote hedge wick and the
angry itch
and they were like yitzok is a man
played by a woman
a formal former drag queen named crystal
knocked
and they were like you need to bring a
song in and
you know well here's the thing
this is kind of magical so when we did
the workshop
the last song in the show was not
midnight radio yet it was
jon as hedvig singing you light up my
life in german
and i have no idea why i was not asked
to
but to my audition and i had never sung
this song before
i don't know why i sang you light up my
life
lies i swear to god for real i'm not
lying
i don't know why why on earth
would you pick that song i don't know
wait john
so were you at the audition john yeah
it must have stuck in my brain because
you know later
uh that was sort of our temporary finale
i feel like when i met john and stephen
and peter i just sort of was like
i kind of feel like i met my people and
i kind of understand
this person even though he's not really
a person yet you were so good at kind of
explaining
his pain but somehow i just tapped into
that that
rage and that sadness that is yitzhak
and it just felt weirdly familiar and
i just was excited to go on that trip i
didn't know we had no idea at that point
we weren't off broadway yet
it was still very new and you guys were
like we don't really know if she can
sing but we kind of like her
yeah and and i take credit for i take
credit for that because
we each had names written on our piece
of paper
and we'd like turn them over like peter
and johnny and miriam was our first
choice and we're like
i don't know if we if she's in but she
just seems like one of us we like her
miriam also taught me a weird thing that
happens with actors it's like
you can do things if your character can
you know that you can't
in your life and miriam hadn't really
sung rock roll
but the character had to scream you know
rock and roll and suddenly because the
character had to
she could and i find the same thing with
me i can like
catch a ball really easy if i'm in
character but in real life i'm like oh
my god
you know the world of musical theaters
i just always felt kind of i always felt
like i was trying to fit into that world
because
i just felt like i'm like clearly much
more of a freak than
is allowed in that world and i just felt
right at home when i met you and
john's team i just felt like yeah
an interesting thing with the with the
flow of gender in the show which is
throughout is um originally that
character was more of a fact totem
someone helping out with props and that
was craig chester played the
version of that named georg and when we
were thinking of the real show
stephen said you know be great if that
character could be a backup singer and i
would love to hear
high registered voice so i was like
let's have a person born female with a
high voice
or available high notes
playing a man who wants to dress as a
woman
so in effect you know and
a uh an a fab actor playing a man
who wants to do drag um
and it was the it was perfect for the
piece because
we want the audience throughout to be
not confused but like
aware that the world is fluid you know
we are
all we all have these energies that
sometimes we call male and female
in us and we can pull them out when
needed
others are more natural but some are
hidden and if you don't
let them come out it's like an animal
that dies in the wall
it can really stink the place up and you
know
we were always aware of the flow you
know
edvig was a boy named hansel who was
comfortable in his gender
and forced into assigned a gender by
in effect the patriarchy by his
boyfriend and by the government
and is left alone and just you know
crushed after that and it's through drag
that peppermint reminded me is where the
empowerment happens
not necessarily through a trans journey
because it was more of a victimization
but taking what you've got
using drag rock and roll performance to
find yourself to create
yourself as hedvig is the journey
and a lot of people can relate to that i
get a lot
especially trans masculine people
say i love the flow of gender in this
because as a
trans masculine person i want to be able
to do female drag
i don't want to be limit limited by
anyone i want freedom
and hedvig's journey to freedom is a
danger is a
lot of obstacles but and hopefully
there's fewer obstacles
in real life for uh for others but
the character allowed a little space
that all kinds of people with different
kinds of backgrounds and genders
found the space to be within and that's
we we love that yeah i mean i will say
too playing itself
it was such a gift to get to
explore what being a man means
you know to me as a person i get i got
to
just explore that every night and not
just that but what
a man who wants to be a drag queen so i
got to really
go on a journey that you know was not
afforded
people you know this is the the 90s
that's that wasn't
i mean it's still a struggle for a lot
of people and it felt like such a gift
it felt like
the point was just to explore it and
share it
with everybody watching in that moment
you know
it was kind of extraordinary for all of
us i think
i think we and you could feel it it was
so
visceral in the theater sometimes you
know it's just really electric and i
remember
when we thought that maybe it
was going to be a movie too which just
seemed extraordinary because we were
such
underdogs for so long like we always
joked like
oh yeah we're going to be on broadway
and like 178th street like you know it's
never going to be on broadway let's not
kill ourselves when they talked about oh
you know this could be a film i remember
thinking
how are you gonna translate that
intersection
of excitement and fear and transgression
and acceptance you know that that the
play was able to do
so that was kind of an exciting journey
i mean i was like i said it was my first
freaking
audition in new york so i was like oh is
this how art goes
[Laughter]
miriam you mentioned a bit of the
journey from
the workshop to off-broadway to the
movie
i'm guessing there were several
challenges but one of the big
changes was of course with costumes um
and i'd so i'd like to introduce this
next person
who is one of the most unique and
creative forces in the fashion
and entertainment industries a
multi-dimensional artist
visual artist who brings her exemplary
vision to film fashion theater
opera music and media
oh i love her so much please help me
welcome
arianne phillips hey ariane
thanks peppermint so happy to be here
i'd love to hear
uh your experiences from once you first
got on board how did it begin that's
very bittersweet that
i came to hedwig through our incredible
production designer
tourette's depray who's not with us
anymore who we had worked on a project a
film together
and she recommended me to john
and i got the script um
for the movie and i honestly didn't know
what i
was reading i was i was like i don't
know what the hell this
is but it's [ __ ] genius um there was
animation
and puppets and you know not your
typical
you know camera angle you know panning
left panning right dolly moves there is
incredible
character development and i didn't hear
the music because i hadn't seen the show
i'd heard about it i got the script i
read it i just knew
i read it a couple times because i
really couldn't figure out which way was
up or down but i got the emotion
and the heart i trusted tres implicitly
and then i went to i think it was the
avalon
hotel and um i met
mike and i was in the pool same time
yeah mike you were in the pool the
kidneys
immediately i can really echo what
miriam said that like i felt like these
are my people you know working
in this industry we are thrown together
with so
many different types of people that's
the brilliance and you know
different backgrounds different
aesthetics and being
a theater nerd as a kid i
immediately um just felt
seen in a way just by reading the script
and
fell in love with john and mike at the
same time and
you know will forever be grateful to
tres to pray for bringing me in
and for john taking a shot on me
and i went to new york shortly
thereafter and saw the show
on jane street i think the first show i
saw was with ali sheedy
actually and i remember john
you saying you know you've got to see it
you know with someone else as well
so that was how i came to the film and
um
you know 20 years later some of you know
my family
uh close closest you know we've had the
pleasure of going through this
you know unprecedented journey and
hedwig is always um
you know how i explain it hedwig is my
rocky horror picture show when i saw
rocky road picture show as
uh as a kid it was so
provocative and it was about a similar
message in terms of
you know don't dream it be it uh finding
your true identity and
and using the artifice of you know
sparkles and hair and makeup um to
express yourself
and you know everything in between and
so much heart
and i feel so privileged to be
part of this family and it's a
connection
i have with strangers whether they find
me on the internet or hear
about it on set it's multi-generational
it crosses so many cultures
and ages and there's no boundary and my
grandmother
who isn't with us anymore i remember
when she saw the film
she she was so blown away by it and
you know and that's the power of
beautiful story
and compelling music and brilliant
performance and
and just doing this film as turned out
to be
the most representative of who i am as
an artist in terms of my creativity
and i just really felt
that encouraged by everyone john and
stephen and
frank's beautiful work mike endlessly
you know our
my costumes are completed by his work
and
we're inspired by his work and there's
not a beginning and
end like most projects you know we all
were are so
connected and and the performers so
that's my monologue
okay this is perfect timing it's time
for me to bring in our next
genius who grew up in baltimore maryland
right
near where i grew up and studied
classical piano
into his late teens while learning
italian in florence italy
he had the opportunity to work on a tv
commercial there and was immediately
drawn to filmmaking
and now works in features tv shows
commercials documentaries industrials
webisodes
art films music videos you name it and
he has done it
of course i'm talking about frankie
demarco
okay frankie please tell us how you
came on board yeah yeah i uh i came
through it through the sundance film lab
through michelle satter who was
running a sundance summer director's lab
michelle was looking for dp's i think
she had to already talk with john and
just based on the timbre of my voice and
probably the timbre of john's voice she
thought
these two probably get along pretty well
so i went and did the lab and to
ariane's point about like
there's the standard way to shoot
everything and when we were doing the
lab i
i remember we had these sets that just
were so overused
i said why don't we flip the set around
so we're looking at the back of the set
that has the
exposed water so we just kept on i think
reading the script and seeing how john
works and he's willing to fail and try
again and
fail and try again that's always sort of
been my mantra too
is i'm willing to fail let's try it and
john encouraged that and so
we got along very well at the lab and
time passed and then we ended up working
at john's apartment which john and i
lived nearby at the time and it would
often most of the time be john and
therese duprey the production designer
myself
and we went through the script page by
page by page
and picked the script apart and talked
about think through ideas out
and you know john cherry picked the best
ideas and made changes
john how did the movie come about and
tell me about the challenges of being a
first-time director
well it was a strange situation like i
mentioned uh
stephen strask had connections with new
line cinema
so did i uh bob shea
who ran new line was really my godfather
with this
and bob directed me in the show uh in
the movie book of love
and in my audition i hadn't read the
script until i got in the office
and he said what do you think and i said
you know my character is really written
very homophobically
bob i have to be honest and this was
like an 88
and people didn't really say those
things and he's like
well it's it's homoerotic i'm like
well homogeneous begins with
homo as well they all mean different
things
um so the characters are
very you know every negative stereotype
and
he said oh you know i didn't think of
that so how would you do it if it was
you know rewritten and
he eventually rewrote it but years later
he came to the show
on the behest of mike deluca and there
were tears in his eyes after and he said
you know you were very
s straight with me in a
creative engaging way with book of love
and
i appreciated that and i'd like to help
you i'd like to finance this film and
they were supportive of me directing it
and starring in it wouldn't happen now
you know it would have to be some big
star
you know and suddenly we were the hot
thing
so everyone would show up you know danny
devito was
really wanted to produce that forest
whitaker wanted to direct
i said to forrest i actually would like
to directly said john that would be a
terrible mistake
and i was like forest
i hardly know you oh she's a forest
that's what she said i mean i hadn't
directed before so it wasn't a bit of a
risk i directed it on stage
so it was a strange moment when you know
independent film it's not edit you know
it's not hip anymore it's not
part of the zeitgeist it was in the 90s
in the 2000s it was
numbers of companies who were financing
and we had a bidding war amongst a
number of companies even though we were
not a big hit
financially we were a critical hit and
we had an opportunity
so we knew we really wanted to work with
new line and eventually we brought in
uh killer films christine bashan
who's my hero you know worked with todd
haynes and
all these great people we also had a
good year to work on it so i went to the
lab
met frank you know remember the first
time i directed a scene
on film it didn't go that well the
second one
michelle said to me you're a filmmaker
now and i started crying and it was a
beautiful experience and i
i trusted frank even though he didn't
have
you know the credits necessarily that
new line wanted
i had a great vibe with him and i said
no to all these
more famous dps and and that was
the right decision because frank marco
and
andrew marcus the editor in many ways
were co-directors for me they were much
more experienced andrew had worked with
merchant ivory you know
room with a view howard's zen remains of
the day
and frank was this gutsy scrappy new
york
based guy coming up from the pit
and uh it was a perfect mix and
stephen had these connections with new
lines too so there was a kind of
family vibe with new line
where we felt safe do you think that
made you feel more safe to direct
yourself because i think that sounds
like the ultimate nightmare
that was very scary um in some ways
doing the show
i was kind of directing myself then too
and never being able to see it because i
was on
stage so i was used to kind of
directing but it was and i had my i knew
what i loved you know when i knew i
loved altman and cassavetes and
bob fosse you know and all that jazz
in some ways was the most influential on
this you know the idea that
each scene could have yeah the fact that
each scene could have a different style
and if there was a strong narrator or
that you could hold those different
styles
together so it was it was films like
that
and uh nashville that i was thinking
about
for this you know a lot of 70s stuff and
i like the fact that even kids today
can't tell when this was made they're
like 70s 80 you know it's like it
doesn't
have that it's out of time which i like
and frank and i made sure
we shot it on film and that was a big
deal so
we had an unusual situation where we had
financing
distribution before we even shot
and we had a good year to develop it
and go through every scene frank and i
there would be
no way we could shoot it if we didn't
have that year i didn't have enough
experience
we bit off way more than we can do i'm
often over there putting a wig
on while frank is shooting you know the
grips
ass as this you know substitute asks for
myself
and andrew the editor is shooting gummy
bears
in close up and i'm like just like
squeeze box we're just
barely getting it together we organized
what was called the insurgency
ariane mike and frank stole
costumes and makeup frank stole stock
film stock and had his own camera and we
shot some scenes
in my apartment in toronto on a weekend
illegally
and shot you know stuff without sound
with my
pit in me that ended up in the film and
we would never have got those things if
we hadn't broken
all the rules you know even the crew was
overwhelmed with our rock and roll style
i remember the a.d
was just he would just he started crying
and we ended up having to
assist and direct it too i was like move
those trucks we had drag day and all
this
canadians they wouldn't even take my
help sorry you and i were like the least
drag out of all the the a.d showed up in
like tutus
you had these people who i think until
this film would never have it would not
have occurred to them to think about
drag teamsters and drag and it was a day
where everyone was in drag and that's
how we shot that day
that would be my ultimate thing that's
how i see the world
everyone is in drag put your frame of
mind
there to to be a drag performer even in
the smallest way like it just opens
something for you and
if everyone on set is doing that it's
just going to open something up
and already such a scrappy sense on that
film
very much like what you were talking
about steven and john when you were
talking about being
off broadway the way that hedwig was off
broadway was not like we had to
fake it it was whatever happened was
what happened
and being on that stage was reacting to
whatever happened
i've never felt more alive in the moment
of a theater piece and that was very
much
translated to the screen i was gonna say
we lost one of the
the locations and then we just had to
shoot that tire scene
remember that and it was like that's
right that feels right for
for a headache that you're scrappy and
that you you have to make do with what
you have and that it actually is
beautiful
it becomes the beauty of the piece too
is that it evolves
around kind of the circumstance you're
in that day
when you're performing or shooting and
and you know it lives on
it kind of edwig has her own energy and
that's why it's
authentic at any time if you missed also
only had two costumes in this
original stage production but in the
film she had 41.
so can you talk about that and how you
would go from 2 to 41
well the first thing i said to ari who
you know
earlier work blew me away i said all
right
cr hedwig's costumes have to be creative
unique
and affordable because she is working
out of thrift shops
and aria's like done you know she
brought in
stuff from earlier movies she'd worked
on or abandoned
or rock and roll music stylist stuff i
was wearing
britney spears's skirt i was wearing
cameron diaz's shirt
it was like she was a hermit crab and a
scavenger
right ari well yeah i mean what i would
say it's like method costuming right
like getting into the character doesn't
stop with the actors it's really like i
always say that
costumes are a beam me up suit for an
actor to access
a time and place in the character and i
take that seriously like just the
unfortunately for john i mean it was
torturous
well it was torture i mean like you know
mike potter and i
cutting the hair dress in you know mike
and john
crying literally on a saturday in in our
hotel
because it shaved his eyebrows off
yeah we still haven't recovered except
revita brow peppermint we already
already remember when we went to the
remember we went to the valley
and we went to the buy the pound stores
and you
got some really great like that maul
costume
like the ricky lee jones like pink with
the beret
it was like aria had all these great
resources that was like so hot
like high the words like good will bad
will
but like a lot of low but ari's can
always make it
beautiful like somehow john you you know
you tasked me with that and that is
just the kind of meaning that
i could put into those costumes and and
it was it was doable and really like
fun and ripping them apart and putting
together as hedwig would
and actually i think that that has
informed me in my work ever since
to try and approach the costumes
uh as if how a character dresses
themselves or what the character
and hedwig was just uh riches and gifts
that kept on giving mike can you tell us
about her hair
and her look in the movie 30 wigs
that sounds like a fantasy and a
nightmare all at the same time so i went
in and the studio was like well we're
gonna have you oversee
and you're not gonna do john like we
have other people on like
union people and i'm like i'm the only
person that's touching john
i didn't have an assistant i had to do
some of those wigs and triplicate
john never wanted to wear a bobby pin so
they would fly off his head and it would
be like cut the wig flew off
but i just remember a lot of like ariane
teaching me
like it was my first movie i ever did
was hedwig i think ariane
was really a guiding force for me and
john let us at a certain point
kind of do what we wanted and i did i
came from that drag
old drag you know don hill's world where
you know you threw together
a bunch of you know things and you know
luckily ari had things a little more
planned out but i just remember
we had planned out wigs well we had
looks planned out and then at the last
minute they would just change
and or or ari would be like this is all
i got is this and like these glitter
shoes and i'm like okay i'm gonna do a
lip to match the shoes
not that you would ever see them
together but we tried to connect
and i think having the freedom to um
be allowed to do what we wanted to do
and i come from kind of a like sort of a
like a little bit of a trashy
background it comes from like sharpie in
your dark
roots that's you yeah yeah yeah i give
all my
like cred to ariane i mean i always tell
people i'm like
she taught me everything i know about
like working on a film
can we talk a little bit about of the
production designer therese duprey
therese in some ways was i mean aria too
but tres in some ways was more
had worked longer in film than any of us
and i knew her from the killer film
stage she did a
film called uh dottie get spanked with
todd haynes and you know she was the
hip new york person she was seven feet
tall
she had the best taste in the world her
apartment was just full of [ __ ]
that was beautiful her wedding was the
most designed wedding of
all time i sang a version of love and
she
was pure you know she was pure
new york cool hip without the attitude
just sweetie she came in and brought in
an ari because they've been working
together
i brought in mike and frank and andrew
was new to all of us
and stephen of course is bringing in his
musical people from
different angles too so a lot of people
who didn't have film experience but we
had
grand old torres who did a very
difficult shoot
you know i'm not sure how it was like
really hard on her physically
he never slept never slept magician
never slept
every detail you know bilgewater's
restaurant
the worst seafood restaurant in the
world with decorations of
of sinking ships on the wall it was a
sinking ship
themed cgi fridays layers of
story and detail like the oven and the
german apartment
and oh my so much it was more than we
could afford
no afford more than we were worth you
know we had
tons of references so we were all in the
same world when it was time to shoot
uh because usually films people don't
work unless they're on the clock and we
were
all working for nothing early on
usually it's like three months before
right and that's why things are
look half fast these days but this
looked considered
thought through fun varied and
i was learning from them because i only
knew what i liked i didn't know exactly
how to do anything
i want to ask the whole panel about the
movie and how cinematic it was with
the bouncing ball animations and just
like all the things that were done with
the split screens
that you couldn't do in the stage
version i'd like
just free for all it no i was just gonna
say i mean
because we were shooting a live action
movie
no longer a stage play on one single set
with no set changes
and we had to work with an animator
emily
emily we also had a lot of visual
transitions because we would go
from live action to animation back to
live action
and we had to know you have to film
in such a way that this cuts together so
i think the year literally we had a year
of
free preparation meeting at each other's
apartments it really helped because the
movie has a ton of transitions and i
think it's part of the charm and the fun
of
the movie that go from east berlin
suddenly bang or into
this next place or whatever animation or
another new set
that question i asked before which i
kept asking myself which was like how
are we gonna
translate this visceral energy
of doing live theater way over on the
west side highway when that was a place
people were unsure of it wasn't a cool
hit place
there was a sense of subversion and
danger in that play
and we are all in it together and i was
like how are you going to translate that
into a movie how are you we all going to
be on this ride together
how are we going to feel like it's
dangerous yet inclusive
and subversive yet home you know what i
mean like how is that going to come
together
and i feel like everyone put so much of
themselves into it when i watched it i
was like oh that's how you're going to
use
everything you can use in film and throw
out a rule book that tells you you can't
do that in film
and make sure the glitter looks exactly
right which frank would do with like
well what film will make these this
glitter look perfect or you know
this particular in undergarment that no
one will ever see ariane's gonna make
perfect
that immediacy translated and that
alchemy that's in a stage piece that
works
was there in the movie and it's so rare
because it it's almost unnameable but i
mean it has to do with the
heart and the work and the artistry that
gets
you know obsessively put into it and we
were away from home we were all in
toronto we're in a different country
i don't know how many days we had but we
certainly didn't have enough days
that energy of getting it done
and not losing a scene you know stuff
like
for me in post scene like you know
john as hedwig flying over bilgewaters
and
emily's animation and all those tasty
special
vision is what created that other
dimension of
magic and you know there is a magical
reality
in hedwig that is grounded in this
soulful heart story about
being true to ourselves and the alchemy
exactly what you said miriam do you guys
remember if is the wig in the box
you know brady bunch look was that like
one of the last scenes we shot
do you guys i think i think it was and
it was like we'd been up all night
we were laughing during that we all got
the giggles you're in this height and
we're so exhausted
like heightened reality of like having
shot for so long
and then we're doing this absolutely
fantastically absurd thing
like you can see it in the shot if
you're watching us that we're all barely
holding on and keeping it together it's
funny because when i
wrote the original script i didn't think
budget
and headlight was performing in a lot of
different places like
a airport lounge you know there was
going to be a conveyor belt camera shot
just discovering her you know in the
airport lounge singing
then an arrest stop and then we in a box
was going to end up in a garbage
scow you know barge off of staten island
with the helicopter shot
and you know christine basham was like
what if it's the same restaurant but a
different
branch every time like all right
and then it was bilge waters which was
fun and we used the same restaurant
different angles of it so it's again you
take what you know the hermit
crab thing you take what you got and
then you gussy it up and that is the
spirit of drag
but there was one thing about that to me
like the greatest moment
was the wall of the
uh trailer coming down and when john and
therese and i were in pre-pro
we were talking it was originally
written as a daylight scene i said what
if it were a nighttime scene could it
does it matter if it's day or night
john's like no that doesn't matter
that'd be okay i said
well what this is such a spectacular but
when the music changes and it opens up
and goes crazy and they're shimmying and
shagging
i said can't we like can't be like blow
off the roof and then have all four
walls
fold down and it becomes this crazy
stage or something and therese you know
she has to i don't deal with money
teresa deals with budget and she's like
guys we
we can't do that there's okay fine but
then she said you know what i
i did a movie once where i had one wall
come down i can give you one wall and
then john's like well we'll put foot
lights on the wall that
just became and that became the movie it
was brilliant that was to me one of the
most charming moments and then when we
actually get
came to the day to film it i was very
worried about how am i going to film
this as a cinematographer
and i remember like i just i was having
panic the night before
how am i going to do this this is a
setup for failure then i put on the song
i had like a little
one of those tape deck players in my
hotel room in toronto and i put the song
on
i listened to the song and i realized no
problem we're going to do this
so thank you an example of the rock and
roll too exactly
we're under a we're under a power pylon
you know the
the trailer park's under you know one of
those towers and
frank is like again in the spirit of
squeeze box
there's like two electrical grips
one with the light and one with a cd
that's reflecting that r clamp
onto the pylons of the uh
that's that crazy light on there it's
just a cd
that's crazy that was the money shot too
i think
totally that because that was that when
you had the cur you had the
you know like the full pullback and i
was yeah right yeah we had yeah
the animation with the bouncing ball
totally
just a lot going on only the crazy
sick twisted mind of john and stephen so
stephen i want to ask
about shooting the musical numbers
i'm curious how much if any did the
score change for the film
we just rocked harder everything about
it just felt
more aggressive than on the stage it was
more guitar heavy
a little more punk and what was one of
the things that was really fun for me
besides re-recording the songs
and getting a different sound was that
actors all
learned to play these
of the people that they were playing so
i mean obviously i was playing my own
parts
uh bob muelled was not in it ted
lizinski who played bass
on the recording played the guitar
player and so bob taught him how to play
all the parts and then um
the guy who played the bass player ted
taught him how to play all the stuff
they came to the rehearsals
and the and and michael learned how to
play the drum parts he knew
every drum part the way that we did it
um on with all the musicians actually
looking like they were playing the
instruments
and then the monitors that they had next
to them that looked like they were
listening to them
were actually playing their part out
into the
into the house and so then we had this
audience of extras who actually believed
they were at a concert
so we were there doing it and they were
responding like they were
like they were like they were seeing a
band perform and none of us were
actually playing
but it gave but it gave that impression
and and
it was it felt kind of it felt very
magical
and we did it just really quickly can
everybody tell me your favorite moments
or memories from the shoot and the film
uh i would say
therese and i were next to the camera
and we
john was singing origin of love and we
both were crying
by the time the song ended holding each
other it was very sweet
yeah mine was every day at lunch
john would have to shave his face in
full
drag and we would never know like was
the makeup gonna like what was gonna
happen because you know
we would shoot all the close-ups at the
end and it was always like
40 filters but i just remember john
every day at lunch
full drag and you know directing in the
chair but he would just shave
you can't shave through makeup if it's
an electric yes you can
i have to say that last shoot that last
wig in a box
moment with us singing the song and it
was
the end of the shoot and we sort of knew
that and was this sort of really magical
uh moment and we were all just insane by
the end of the night and the end of the
shoot
um that and then also the moment where
hedvig gives yitzhak the wig in
that we shot that was just a really it's
always an emotional moment for
me you know playing it sock but um
it was so beautiful the way that it was
shot that the whiteness the
the torres i mean just the look of it in
that moment and then people catching me
as i fell back and then it was my i got
to be in drag
i felt like an alien angel you know it
was just this culmination
so it was like a it was a really meta
moment where i felt like yitzhak was
getting a dream and i was
also getting a dream to sort of come
true in that moment the one thing i just
remember there is actually one song
which is hedwig's lament
which was the one time it felt like
everything had stripped down and it and
john and i are both performing live
the piano is the piano that you hear is
me playing whatever piano it was that
happened i don't even know if we tested
that piano
it was not like the most awesome piano
in the world but it was it was
perfect for that song in that whole like
production where everything just kind of
blew up into
much larger proportions and then just
before
it blew up there was this one moment
where it like
zeroed in on just john and me performing
live together
which somehow feels like really special
to me
i had a lot more fun directing other
people than myself i think in the moment
during
tommy's wicked little town when tom is
singing to hedvig
in this black void and i was able to let
go
you know and and cry you know it been so
much
tension i don't think i had taken a [ __ ]
for a month an anal
fissure ouch okay
hello ouch you know
i it was such a journey harder than
anything
i will ever do and you know before
or since or in the future even though i
didn't really want to act in that
because i had done that
that was an opportunity to to cry
in a good way you know hedwig is crying
for the
the boyfriend finally apologizing and
letting go letting her go him
being let go as well and that's the
beginning of forgiveness because hedvig
is a victim
acts like a victim throughout i'm a
[ __ ] victim
and it's very mean to people because of
it i got hurt therefore i'm going to
hurt you i'm justified
in hurting which is what so many people
feel right now it's like everyone is a
professional victim
and i admire the people who create the
professional alternatives
yes we know there are grievances we know
there's injustice
what are you going to do rather than
saying you're hurting me
or i hate you you're you know you're
cancelled it's like
where do how do we create the
environment when we find the things in
common
where we allow people to even change
you know but i i really
think hedwig's story has resonated for
more people than we expected
because we've all felt put upon we've
all felt like a victim
and if you stay in that mode even if
you're the most
powerful victim you're still under the
power of the person
who hurt you and you've got to find a
way to forgive
and if they don't take the forgiveness
then you'd move on
john you've said that hedwig hedwig is
not
a trans story um and you talked a little
bit about this but can you go in a
little bit
on what hedwig is about if it's not a
trans story for people who
who might describe it as such yeah i
really don't see it as i don't think
that's the best way to look at it uh
it is a story of of this boy hansel
who is in a lot of cages there's the
cage of
east germany there's a place that is not
welcoming to his
very creative queer side he is in a cage
of masculinity
that he feels there's more space for
more
femininity whatever you want to call it
it's a person who is
raped as a child which is implied you
know raped by his father
there is abuse throughout ultimately
there is this
operation that he's kind of forced into
by his boyfriend and mother
and in fact his government to be free
you have to be
you have to change your gender and this
is how we define
your gender no penis means you're a
woman
what a horrible way to define femininity
is with a negative and the inch
being a metaphor for what is left
of that abuse what is the scar
the remnant of these people having hurt
him
and when he does end up in a trailer in
kansas
alone abandoned by that man who in
effect mutilated
him without much consensual choice
not allowing him as steven said to go on
his own gender journey but forcing it
that's an example of top-down
forcing yourself people into these
narrow places they didn't expect to be
we all end up in these narrow places and
we've all had some
bruises and hopefully not as horrible
uh wounds that that hedwig has
experienced and then
there is the next step which peppermint
you identified
as self-creation to me which is like in
effect
in drag which is a tool that anyone can
use
straight cis queer trans
can use drag in a special way
to defend yourself with armor
but also to create a canvas to express
yourself
safely that is when a head big puts on
the makeup
finds that wig and makes something
beautiful and new which is neither
which is more than a man and a woman it
is an a gender of
one and so that's why i don't think i
mean it's a
tran trans in the terms of
crossing boundaries yes but not
necessarily
the traditional the definition of
transgender which is
i'm finding myself through agency
through volition
through sometimes physical changes
sometimes
just identification but the
deeper elements of finding yourself
through the woods
through the abuse is one that
trans friends have told me have they
found
use in the headband cis friends
queer friends gay friends straight folks
outsiders all and to limit
the character being played by one
category or another goes against its
actual message
which is self realization and finding
your own
wholeness in the end hedwig doesn't even
need the tool of dragon anymore and
in horror and frustration tears it off
and walks into the world
naked you know with a scar
saying take me as i am or
don't take me at all i no longer need
this defense
and i see hedwig now as a
probably a non-binary professor of
german philosophy and rock and roll in a
small midwestern college
about to lose your job and health care
i will take that course anytime i want
to ask each of you about the endorsed
enduring legacy of hedwig
and when you became aware
that hedwig had become such a cult
classic
i think the first time i knew it was a
cult hit when michael
who's my husband got a job at the
university of kentucky in 2004
i started going to clubs i met
this guy dwayne lundy who owned a
recording studio in town and
he was working with a band called parlor
boys and i met him at at one of their
shows and he was recording them
and he was already a huge hedwig fan
then i started hanging out with the band
and i became friends with them and
everyone in their circle of friends who
are who are like
just very creative and
and very like progressive millennials
and they all knew that they all knew the
movie and they'd all watched it in high
school everybody
everybody knew it when they were all big
fans and like and i remember go
and then i started going to clubs to
hear bands and meet people
at the clubs like and they're always
like 24 and they'd be like oh my god i'm
such a huge fan
and i was in con and we're in lexington
kentucky and i was like
i didn't have any clue that that was
going on
in the country as a whole for me the
legacy
personally is that hedwig changed the
trajectory of my
choices that i've made um in my
in my career and in my artistic life
and it recalibrated who i
went into blindly um pursuing and so i'm
forever grateful for that
and on the larger level it has
fostered a conversation that i have with
strangers
about meaning and purpose and
joy and celebration and pride
in so many different forms and a
connection to strangers
and um and then the physical legacy is
that
um it was the only film i ever owned my
the costumes for which was the deal i
made with
christine vashon and katie ramel the
producers because they couldn't pay me
enough money i said okay i'm keeping the
costumes
and i have donated almost all the
costumes
to the ampus museum so they have a
permanent home i've donated all my
sketches and will live on and hopefully
that physical legacy
people will get to enjoy the the
costumes in future exhibitions and so
i'm
i'm super grateful for that i keep
meeting people
every day who you know were effective i
had big
um here in brisbane you know eve i was
trying to get
my rent stabilized apartment form
notarized here in brisbane and
the secretary is like you know he had he
had the same name as you know
you know an actor on broadway have you
heard of hedwig and the angry inch and
i'm like that's me and she's like no
right so it it filters
not in a massive you know kind of
shoved down your throat by marketing you
know marvel universe way
it bubbles up from the bottom you know
it it's
passed on word of mouth a person gives
it to a friend
the dvd or what you know now it's just
the streaming like
people i've heard of multiple people
saying
when i start dating someone i have shown
the films to them and if they don't like
it we don't continue
dating you know i love being a you know
a dating litmus test and
you know and it kind of resonates again
throughout sexualities ages
genders uh race you know there's a sense
of
understanding when you've been knocked
down and you're trying to
put yourself back together find your
wholeness find that other half
even if it's an internal other half and
it's found its way the countries that
have
have welcomed it most korea japan
spain australia france
you know these are places we didn't
expect to resonate
with something unusual you know because
korea and japan aren't
super queer you know relaxed places
but the story itself especially korea
where it's
you know i'm actually a rock star in
korea you know
stephen and i can go there and perform
to ten thousand people one night
and k-pop stars show up and they're like
we love handwriting
and partly it's you know their their uh
flag is the yin yang symbol which is
similar to our headtakes
you know this is a broken nation just
like germany was broken
so the queer stuff aside we get so many
people resonating to different parts of
the story
which is so gratifying to us and the
people i've met just because of this
project
are some of my favorite people it keeps
giving when i
meet you know a trans kid in sydney
who's just coming up and saying you know
you gave me a little bit of of hope that
there was some space for me to make
myself not make myself in the image of
hedvig
or you but make my own journey
that is the most empowering compliment
any artist can have is that it made
someone feel that they could do
something they didn't know they could
that has helped them i think that it's a
piece of art about identity
about national identity right it's one
of the only pieces of american art i
know of that deals with berlin wall
falling
and the berlin wall was this moment of
identity for everyone people all over
the world
identified who they were as nations
based on which side of the wall they
were
on you know and we sort of forget that
now because it's gone it just dissipated
and disappeared but it was how people
define themselves as
as nations yeah and this and that same
split this idea that you could so
unnatural to split something and say
pick a side
you cannot go there's a no man's land in
between you don't get to go over it
or you'll die you know that kind of
feeling of like searching for identity
it was so beautifully put into this
piece that was like
you know east west germany but also male
female yin yang
and who are you in that world where do
you exist
when do you get to make that decision
and i feel like hedwig
asked that question with music which is
the most visceral
way to ask a question you know um and
and people just responded to it because
it was it asked that question
of you when you watch it and some people
maybe it felt like the first time they
were allowed to answer
in the last 20 years john since uh the
movie
was released what would hedvik think
and he was like what am i money epic
exactly i'm playing joe exotic right now
and there's a lot in common with edmond
right sudden fame you know
jealousy anger young boyfriends
you know before the pandemic i would
have not understood that but now i
totally get it
yes what do you think stephen
what would have been doing now i think
that she
well i think she thinks there's too many
too many walls not enough bridges
that's right you find the point of
connection between you and another
and and another person another group and
and you can make it into a wall or you
can make it into a bridge and edward
would prefer to make it into a bridge
okay so i want to say thank you to each
of you
for uh for spending time i want to say
thank you to
everyone watching and of course i want
to say thank you to the academy which
i've always wanted to say
i have no business
john stephen ariane mike miriam
frankie thank you so much
congratulations
to each of you and to everyone that had
anything to do with this film with the
uh
off-broadway with the workshop with the
west end with the broadway production
any iteration and of course the many
many people who have the fortune
to work on and be associated with or any
of the subsequent productions
uh that have been on stage uh thereafter
congratulations
to 20 years and thank you so much on
behalf of
so many people who are gender expansive
gender
explorative and beyond
thank you peppermint we love you
peppermint
thank you
[Music]
you